si la tendance se maintient la facture
du panier d'épicerie va encore une fois
grimpé en 2020 vous savez chaque famille
va devoir dépenser environ 500 dollars
de plus qu'en 2019 pour se nourrir selon
ça c'est selon a fait le rapport annuel
sur les prix des aliments réalisé par
les université dalhousie et golf
l'auteur du rapport s'appelle sylvain
charlebois vous le connaissez les
directeur principal du laboratoire des
sciences analytiques en agroalimentaire
à l'université dalhousie il est avec
nous ce matin sylvain charlebois
bonjour pas pour une fois vous voir
personne en début d'année c'est bien
bonnes résolutions c'est une bonne
résolution
on voudrait plus souvent à personne mais
c'est bien vous êtes souvent disponibles
pour nos entrevues
le prix du panier d'épicerie qui semble
augmenter plus rapidement que les
salaires sont plus que vous constatez
non ouais nous on présentait notre
deuxième rapport annuel la descente des
bus des saints mais puis malheureusement
on annonçait l'époque que 2020 était
pour être la quatrième année consécutive
dont le taux d'inflation alimentaire et
pourrait était pour dépasser le taux
d'inflation général alors c'était aussi
évidemment et les gens se rendent compte
87 % des canadiens en fait centre que
justement il ya un recul de ce niveau là
bon on dit qu'on va payer quoi 487 $ de
plus qu'en 2019 pour notre panier
d'épicerie on voit des eaux cela
principalement là vous voyez à l'écran
on a mis certaines catégories la
boulangerie ce quoi c zéro à 2% de
l'orientation
c'est dans les fruits légumes quand même
qu'une bonne alimentation et la viande
également si vous aimez le pain je peux
vous aimez le pain vous allez correct
mais pour la forme
elle va rien c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
que
l'inflation vont nous rattraper surtout
dans les viandes on le voit sur le
tableau le cas tu assistes pour ça ça
c'est vraiment la chine c'est le facteur
chinois la chine achète du porc du boeuf
partout dans le monde le brésil
l'australie évidemment ici au canada
c'est pour ça que la chine a décidé de
recommencer à acheter du boeuf et du
porc du canada en octobre ou en novembre
de cette année 2009
alors on voit vraiment que la chine et
suppressions on à 1.4 milliard de
personnes à nourrir alors on achète de
partout incluant le canada est ce que
toutes ces hausses à venir sont
justifiées selon vous qu'est ce qui
explique entre autres cette fluctuation
des prix des domaines j'imagine que
c'est ce que ça dépend de la catégorie
qu'on regarde le même à chaque année le
climat est un facteur celle en 2019
d'ailleurs le prix des légumes avait
augmenté de 15 %
pourquoi il ya eu des rappels alerte
suppose une est décédée à 7 $ bon ça
c'est vraiment raison du fait qu'en
californie il ya eu des problèmes au
niveau du climat sécheresse extérieur
levêque les feux en septembre octobre
alors à chaque année le climat est pour
quelque chose on paye pour lorsqu'on se
nourrit et en 2020 on anticipe on
s'attend à ce que quelque chose qui a
fait que notre panier d'épicerie de
parce que du climat pour ce que dit on
chez nous bien sûr on dit souvent en
cours on encourage nos producteurs
manger local il ya un coup également
mangé le k way généralement
il donnera quand on a affaire à des
circuits courts donc les produits locaux
c'est certain que si on étend la saison
des bonnes aubaines
on peut quand même acheter des produits
à bon prix
par contre si on veut se grattent à
l'année longue c'est pas évident les
prix vont fut tué beaucoup surtout pour
ce qui est des fruits légumes et viandes
et les concentrant le sable on tente de
se protéger mais il ya une chose que
vous pouvez faire pour vous immunise et
de cette inflation à cette visite et le
sur joli la libye sur joli le plus
souvent possible ça goûte est différent
le goût est différent mais l'avoir
intuitive elle sembla en terminant dit
nous et ce phénomène d'augmentation du
prix du panier
est-ce que vous qu'il est égal d'une
province à l'autre vous vous sentez que
dans certaines provinces et des
alimentations plus important on a chip
qui est qui et qui pour avoir une
augmentation plus importante au sein de
deux provinces la colombie-britannique
et le québec
pourquoi ici l'économie va très bien
c'est toujours un facteur
macroéconomique les destructeurs
surveille de très près les gens ont plus
les moyens que les gens des emplois
c'est pratiquement le plein en pro
québec et les epci le sar donc
évidemment on joue on paye qui est pris
à ce niveau là alors c'est pas
nécessairement une augmentation des
cours on veut profiter du fait que
l'économie va bien
ah c'est sûr équilibre seleçao monde
sait ce que les coûts augmentent et on
tente
gérer l'image en conséquence mais les
salaires ne suivent pas c'est ça le
problème
c'est ce qu'on va vivre donc visiblement
en 2020 on va suivre ça avec vous
sylvain charlebois
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin bonnes années 2000 quand même vous
apprenez à vous aussi